[Musique]
c'est à la fin des années 70 que
François Hollande et Ségolène Royal
alors étudiants tombent amoureux royal
et Holland s'affiche ensemble aux
traditionnels rassemblement des
socialistes à La Rochelle mais le couple
qui aura 4 enfants et qui restera
plusieurs décennies ensemble finira par
se séparer peu de temps après la défaite
de Ségolène Royal à la présidentielle de
2007 face à Nicolas Sarkozy je ne
calmerai pas la raison de cette
séparation la double vie que mènerait
François Hollande à ce moment alors
qu'elle s'apprête à sortir un nouvel
ouvrage Ségolène Royal s'est confié au
journal Le Monde sur cette relation
l'ancienne ministre affirme que l'homme
lui aurait été infidèle et lui aurait
imposé une situation de bigamie avec
Valérie Trierweiler jamais plus je
n'accepterai d'être traité comme je l'ai
été en 2007 alors croyez-vous à ces
accusations
alors oui oui
je l'ai rencontré plusieurs fois je peux
vous dire qu'elle a un caractère très
très fort qu'elle a les racines vraiment
non non
je connaissais son frère c'est un amour
ça m'étonne qu'elle est accepté
[Rires]
elle a prouvé le caractère fort qu'elle
a Sacha
de dire qu'elle a imposé une bigamie non
mais tu peux elle a pu aussi imaginer
que c'était une infidélité ponctuelle et
qu'éventuellement il reviendrait dans le
giron et dans le dans le couple et donc
et qu'elle a accepté comme une femme
amoureuse que peut-être éventuellement
ce n'était que passager voilà peut-être
moi ça m'étonne pas parce que c'était
très très chaud entre souvenons-nous que
quand elle a été opposée à Nicolas
Sarkozy à l'élection présidentielle et
bien François Hollande lui avant la
candidature aurait préféré Lionel Jospin
et elle lui avait dit si tu choisis
j'ose pas tu ne reverras plus les
enfants elle avait fait un ultimatum
donc c'était hyper chaud entre eux ça
m'étonne pas du tout et moi je la croise
totalement de toute façon il a refait ça
après avec Valérie
donc
voilà
c'est un peu coupé avec Valérie
glissé non mais c'est ça c'est quand
même hallucinant quoi c'est comme si moi
je trompais Brad Pitt avec George
Clooney c'est quand même improbable il a
dit il a déçu
il doit avoir un talent caché
il est plutôt beau gosse
il a un chat
est-ce que la vie est bien faite c'est
la seule chose que je vous demande non
mais tu vois mais on se dit au-delà
d'être intelligent il est très drôle
chez un homme c'est quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
de tennis
et il fait pipi sur un mur un dimanche à
15h30 avec la stalactite complètement
oui Béatrice l'Amérique non moi j'y
crois complètement il a coutume de ne
pas terminer de façon nette c'est
relations
il passe d'une relation à l'autre mais
c'est vrai que je suis très étonnée par
la beauté de ces conquêtes et je ne
comprends pas parce que je me demande
encore quel charme il doit avoir
tu pourrais avoir une aventure avec lui
non tu peux rien avoir une aventure avec
Bernard Montiel
oui j'aurais pu j'aurais pu dans une
autre vie oui même Hollande dans une
autre ville
c'est comme mon frère
c'est aussi comme comme mon frère
[Rires]
ou pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]